hello everybody oh my gosh am i too loud oh whoa hello oh give me a sec it seems i might be a little too loud oh i'm sorry i'm sorry okay give me a sec give me a sec let me fix this i was like whoa that's loud what the fuck why am i so loud
I think I fucked up.
Okay, give me a sec.
No, I fucked up.
Sorry, sorry, guys.
I, like, unplugged my Google XLR and then, like, I'm back, guys.
I'm back, you know, I'm scuffed as hell.
We're so sorry.
I accidentally, I like unplugged, uh, I, oh, it's like crunchy too, oh, oh, wait, what's going on?
What's going on?
Okay, give me a sec, I'm unplugging my mic and plug me back in.
Give me a sec, guys.
Okay, hello, okay, what?
Okay, give me a sec, I'll, I can fix this.
I unplugged my Go XLR and I plugged it.
back in um but i think that was a bad idea so give me a sec guys
hello okay there we go is it fixed now is it is it better can i have i have i fixed everything is it okay now i don't know is it is it fixed okay yeah okay okay i fixed it all right i it's been so long i'm back from i'm back from vacation guys and i forgot i already i got back in i already forgot how to do stuff um um but hello everybody hello dragons do you guys miss me it's been i don't know it's been almost two weeks too it's crazy uh yeah i forgot how to stream like i i came back and i instantly broke my my sound system i don't know how i did it um i basically was like i was rearranging my um I was rearranging my wires and uh uh because of that um I had to unplug the power for my go XLR and I unplugged like I plugged it back in but I didn't realize how it fucked up uh all right no dough kitty right now that's right I'm holding dough kitty hostage
I just put it on just to match the just to match the intro so if you guys might have noticed a new intro i got super excited uh to show you guys but um i am planning on getting um different variations of the intro for all my different outfits so you'll know like which outfit i'm gonna be using depending on the intro that plays but because like i was like uh for now we're do kitty's not here i just wanted to put doki on just to be like see look do kitty intro there's do kitty
the animator Hoopian just finished the Doakitty one, so I just wanted to show you guys, just wanted to show you guys the new intro.
Yeah, I baited all of you.
So I'm super excited.
We're gonna have, yeah, we're gonna get Crokey, we're gonna get the summer, the beach episode, we're gonna get the school girl, the school girl intro.
So every time I have a new outfit, there's gonna be an intro that matches it.
So that, and there's gonna be like two unique animations uh for um for the intro that matches the outfit itself so i'm super excited too yeah because uh i'm very very excited to see what that comes with it um yeah uh but i am so tired because i'm so fucking jet lagged so for those who don't know we just don't know um i was gone for like almost two weeks because I got invited to uh go to Guangzhou china uh for um at the net ease studio which is uh the marble rivals studio um just to see their get a tour of their campus as well as um check out their very first land so I'm very jet lagged I came back around I think like three days ago I believe I don't know I lost count Time is a social construct.
So I don't even know.
Like two days ago.
I think I came back.
Eating.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Today is an absolute W.
Do kitty intro.
Do keep back.
Life good.
We missed you.
Thank you.
The super chat.
No.
Okay.
I legit.
I think I need to go to a temple or some shit.
Or to like cleanse this cursed energy.
Because my bad luck has not stopped.
like okay um it's it's put i think i'm actually i think i might actually have to go to a temple or some shit and like like have like some like i don't know shaman like like cleanse my soul or something like something's going on like all right for those who didn't don't follow me on twitter um during the plane ride back um uh i did a funny thing where uh for because some people didn't realize uh didn't watch last stream where I was like yeah I have to do a transfer to Tokyo and then then I can go back to Canada so I thought it was really funny where I tweeted I would be like I'm in Tokyo like I'm in Tokyo and then 30 minutes later goodbye Tokyo because I feel so bad because I went on that Tokyo tweet all my Japanese fans would be like oh my god welcome toky welcome to tokyo and then i'm like oh no they don't know it was it was a funny joke though it was pretty funny i i was like okay this shit's gonna be i was like it's pretty fucking funny uh menace thank you for the five gifted chips
thank you thank you yeah my tokyo adventure rta speed road um i felt i was like oh no They think I'm actually in Tokyo for vacation.
They don't know.
I'm just there for like 30 minutes.
Anyway, so what happened was that, you know, during the middle of, like, you know, we were up in the air.
And then the captain was like, I'll reread what I tweeted.
I was so fucking scared.
You guys, I...
He was like, Uh, hello, this is the captain speaking.
A volcano just erupted in our path, and we have to rewrite our flight right now with air traffic control.
So, there will be a slight delay.
While we were in the air.
I know I'm just like What Wait I've been I'll just see you guys you know I've been on planes for A majority of my life I've been traveling you know back Like I've been traveling on planes For the majority of my life Because my parents love traveling And you know sometimes I have to fly back to Asia a lot To growing up to visit relatives this and i've never in my life um had the pilot be like a fucking volcano erupted and we have to reroute while we were flying while we were in the air and then in my head i was like oh please don't crash into another plane i was just like because we're rerouting in the middle our flight so i'm just like oh please don't accidentally get into another plane's fucking round i was like like i had so much fear i i was like please don't make my story into a final destination movie please i do not want to be on mayday i i was like i do not consent to be on like clips of my like beats are like um famous vtuber uh dokeybird was also on that plane and then they
start playing my fucking you like youtube clips i'll be like please oh my i was actually freaking out i was like i do not want to be uh documented on a fucking channel i
a volcano has erupted in the middle of the planes that way and i I was it was actually crazy I I was so fucking scared I I was so I was freaking the fuck out because I was like what were the odds you know what the fuck were the odds that we were gonna fly in the path of a fucking vulcan volcanic eruption I I never heard of this before
I don't know how that has happened.
Anyway, so we landed safely.
I'm here streaming right now.
So, I guess that you all know that I survived.
Thank God.
But, so I thought that was it, you know.
I thought that was where, like, my bad luck ends.
life is so cruel sometimes uh like like decided to to play a cruel joke on me because it was not over because uh i was like you know it was late at night like um for dinner you know i was just like the on the day i got back on the day i got like got back i was like you know what i feel like eating some pho today so I ordered pho and I was like yum yum yum and then you know you know I have a bowl of soup that had to pour out you know so um later in that you know I just kept it on the I just kept it in sync for now and then like later later on I was just like okay I'll clean it later after before I head to bed and then you know I went to bed at like around like I think like 3 to 4 Yeah,
I should I pour my foa into the sink.
So, you know, um, so you know, it wasn't it wasn't like it was a lot of noodles or anything and I've I need you guys to know this I rarely ever pour anything into the kitchen sink ever it's always been like Um, because like, uh, I've never really eaten.
I've never eaten takeout when it comes with soup stuff Because um, I never like because you know, usually I never order takeout with soup with like like, you know, like compared to eating there at the restaurant.
Today, I was just like, you know what?
I'm going to get some fau today.
And so I poured the fau down the sink.
And it was just a little bit of, it was a little out of noodles.
It was just a little bit of noodles.
I have a garbage disposal.
Just so you guys know.
And then It got clogged.
It got clogged.
I've never done this before.
The very first time I ever thrown...
Dumped my pub and down the kitchen sink.
It got clogged.
And I was like, oh, don't worry.
I have a garbage disposal.
So I pressed the button.
But then nothing happened.
And I was like, Why did not go brr?
Where's the sound?
Where's the churning sound?
And I looked at, I was like, and I was like, okay, where's my instruction manual?
I found an instruction manual.
It said it was like, there's a reset button just in case.
There's a reset button on your garbage disposal.
I was like, oh, okay.
And then I pressed it.
I was like, okay, it'll be fixed, right?
And it was like...
It didn't make any sound.
It just did...
And then it stopped.
And I'm like...
No.
And I was like...
Can noodles jog garbage disposal?
And that was And that's when I find out I thought it would cut I didn't realize it could cut What's the point of having A garbage disposal If it It clogs It can clog it What's the point What I don't understand
Didn't understand I've never done this before i didn't know i was like i thought because like garbage disposal it fucking disposed garbage and like i'm like this is garbage like i was like this is garbage well anyway so now i need to call the plumber i haven't called a plumber yet because it's it's not like fully clogged because Like,
after, you know, after I find out that, okay, now I know that soft foods can jam it.
Now I know, guys.
Now, I know.
I didn't know.
But now I know, okay, I didn't know.
Anyway, so it wasn't like, okay, so I found out it wasn't fully clagged because, you know, it was four in the morning.
And then I was just like, I'm going to head to bed.
I was like, I was like, okay.
Well, it's clogged.
And there's, you know, it's just soup base in the sink now because it's not going to go down.
And I was like, it's four in the morning.
I'll call the plumber tomorrow.
So then I, like later in the morning.
So then I, because I was like, it's four in the morning.
I'm fucking, I'm tired and stressed, okay?
I survive a volcanic eruption.
I, I don't want to, I didn't want to deal with this.
So, so.
I was just like, okay, I'm just gonna, I'm gonna go sleep.
I'm gonna go asleep.
And then I wake up, I go to the sink, and I was like, oh, hey, it's God.
You know, like, I was like, oh, hey, look, all the soup's God.
So I'm like, oh, it's not fully clogged, you know, I think there's a tiny hole in there in that clogged.
No, it wasn't magically fixed because if I put too much water there, it stops draining.
So, so I was just like, all right, as long as I, all right, I was like, okay, thinking like, all right, I don't really use the kitchen sink that much anyway because I use, eat like pre-cooked meals.
So I'm just thinking, like, as long as I don't order any soup pans, I was just like, okay I was like I don't need to call a plumber right away because at least like you know at least there's a tiny hole in there so water can go down so I was like okay I'll call plumber later like when I have time because I was just like I was thinking like okay it's water is still draining you know what do not let it rest please okay I will call plumbers soon just maybe tomorrow I'll do it tomorrow I'll do it tomorrow so uh because like I did think about maybe buying a plunger but then I'm like no I could make it worse like with my luck right now I might make it worse and I was like I don't know if I want to play with that,
like, fate right now.
I don't know.
Because I thought about it.
I was like, I don't have a plunger.
I have, like, the other one, the scrappy one, but I don't have a plunger.
So I'm just, I was thinking, like, I could do it myself, yes.
But, like, that's, you're asking the person that just fucking clogged her kitchen sink because she thought the garbage disposal was meant to dispose garbage.
that you're not supposed to...
You're talking to a girl that poured noodles into your kitchen sink, guys.
And apparently you're not supposed to do that.
So I'm like, I don't think I should do it myself.
I don't think so.
So I will call plumber tomorrow.
Maybe not today.
Not tomorrow.
I'll do it tomorrow.
Simple matter.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Do you need a cough Thumper?
It will start to sink Well the best, the good thing is that Like my nose is not very good at smelling things So like I won't notice It until like maybe if it Gets really bad I
But I will do it tomorrow guys Anyway Anyway I will do it Guys I'll do it tomorrow I promise You guys I that's not good thing it's okay dad's at the dog sitter too so like he's it's okay he's at the dog sitter still um i'm picking him up on saturday the reason why he's not back yet is because like oh he's so fucking spoiled by the way at the dog sitter i'm getting like i get like video and picture updates and he's so fucking spoiled um but the reason why is like i'm still sick and i figured like you know let him have a couple of days you know with the dog sitter before he comes back home i don't even know if he still recognizes me as home anymore
but that's why I'm giving him a few more days until he comes back anyway so so I had that happened to me um and then and then after that the next day okay well the reason why the next day I also didn't call a plumber because I had to do a lot deal with a lot of stuff too which was yesterday uh this happened yesterday and um basically what happened yesterday was that so I have like pre-cooked meals um delivered to my place um and you know I had to set up so that you know when I come back from um my when I come back from my vacation I can start eating my pre-cooked meals the day after so they deliver they were going to deliver it yesterday and then I was like um you know I was incredibly jet lagged and so I when I woke up they're like oh it's delivered and I was like that's weird usually have to call me so they can be let in to deliver to my apartment so I was like hmm that's weird and then so um I called I called the um support and they're like oh um we have a they sent us a photo of it
and now it's like they're like is this your is this your apartment door and I looked at it and I saw the apartment number was correct but it was not like my door because like because I have neighbors and it showed that like I had a neighbor like beside me so but the door didn't exist it was just a wall and I was like that's weird and the thing is uh my building it has a neighbor building um it has a neighbor building so they deliver it to the building next door
how because it's never happened before they actually delivered it to the to the building next door and then they just yeah they just left it there and then i like i keep the most fucked up part is that i can't access the floor because like you need the key to access your floor which is why um okay so like uh which is why i feel like it's super safe because like you can't access the floor like even if you're like if you're living on like a different floor uh you can't press other people's floors uh because your key your fob is linked to your specific floor so um so obviously i can't even access the building floor the other different building floor so i have to go to the lobby to the concierge and be like hi um um they your building and like gave it to like the wrong like to the like gave it to this floor number can you like go check for me if it's still there and acacia checked and then she came back down and she's like it's not there so so like they took my pre-cooked meals i was like
i was like that's so up.
I was like, what do you I was like, bro, that's fucked up.
I know where you live.
Because it's the same apartment number as mine.
You're literally next door.
Yeah.
I was like, why the fuck did you take it?
It doesn't have your name and it has a different address.
Like, I I know your number What is it
Um Next to you Thank you Super chat Thank you You really are a curse Yeah so Yes So I I might go to a temple I don't I don't think it's I'm scared I'm actually I'm actually scared I might have to go to a temple And like Cleanse my soul Or something Like Maybe a A fucking dark spirit Attached to my soul or some shit during like when we pass a volcano or something I don't know like I feel like I feel like something attached to me so I have to cleanse my like I'm haunted right now you know so so that so that like I don't know it hasn't stopped I'm I'm scared like you have a baptism stream um um uh but yeah anyway so that's how my bad luck has continued so far uh uh but yeah other than that it was a pretty sweet vacation that's why we're here out at the beach um it was a great it was a really fun vacation uh uh because like i said when i decided i took the request very last minute very hot in my room right now let me open my door real quick uh fudge stop thank you the super chat thank you
thank you yeah i think a ghost is haunting you give it i don't merge them he's a freaky ghost mate thank you with super chat fudge thank you thank you um all right let me end up with my nose real quick before i talk more before i yeah more
want to get cough drops.
Sorry guys.
Doing a little side quest right now.
I need cough drops because my throat is so dry.
Grab my...
Okay.
So...
Yeah, I have like wet coughs right now.
I have so much blood in my throat because of my...
Because of my sickness right now.
um but yes for those who don't realize um i took the yeah that's right ew that's right my bodily fluids disgust you that's when you know i'm real no ai can replicate phlegm in your throat laughing thank you for the super chat thank you thank you keep yapping i enjoy your yaps yeah um
genuine experience.
Oh, when I blow my nose, you're like, oh, why did you mute yourself?
Oh, oh, but when you hear just a tiny bit of a wet cough, you're like, ew, gross, jokey.
Oh, you should have muted yourself.
Hippocrates much, guys.
Goddamn hypocrites.
I want to hear it all.
Lord Croesus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hope your love gets better, Doki.
I'm glad to hear it was at least enjoyable.
Also, it was my birthday two days ago.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course you can, Croesus.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Lord Croesus.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Anyway, what was I going to say?
Oh, yeah.
But I accepted the Marvel Rivals invite super duper last minute.
Literally, like, two days before I was supposed to travel.
I was like, okay, I'm going to do it.
Because at first I didn't want to.
You know, like, my paranoia and shit like that.
Like, I was like, oh, you know, and also, like, traveling as well.
Traveling overseas for long distances.
So I was like, oh, do I do it?
And I was, like, impulsively.
guys you know what i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do it when am i gonna this is like their first land um it's it's their very first land like um so it should be like the experience that you should you should take um because they're trying to you know it's also like by the way um the only people they never they didn't sold any tickets to to watch this land too by the way um because the only way to actually be there at the actual land itself um it's either you're a staff member or like you know family and friends of the players or like invited guests by um um by the the rivals team so they didn't sold any tickets to the public so these were the only ways you could actually like watch the land itself so that's why I was like you know I was like okay I should take try like you know,
take this experience, and why I said yes in the end.
Because like, they asked me like, you know, I remember I told you guys when they invited me, I was like, oh, I'm still thinking about it.
And I remember on that stream, I was like, oh, yeah, no, I'm not going to go.
But then like literally two days before before I flat before I flew, I was like, you know what?
Fuck it.
I'm going to do it.
Because it was such a cool opportunity in general.
And like I knew I wasn't going to experience something like that.
again you know because i think the next land i believe the next land it's gonna be like a public thing so like you know um it's gonna have um i mean the next land is the million dollar land too so like i i'm like i'm not sure if i'm gonna go there i mean it's a million dollar land like that's just crazy dollar land but i did find out i did tell you guys um um on the last stream i was like oh i go into this land made me realize i'm not a land person in general yeah i um it made me realize that i'm not really a land person because like i don't know i think i just like playing video games more than watching like esports i think i think i think that's it i just like playing video games more than watching esports um because like uh oh my god okay so during the finals don't worry guys i have a lot of photos and videos to show you guys too later but during the finals oh my god so the finals is um best of i think it was like best of seven or some shit and the thing about the finals was um was
it was so long because it was best of seven so i was like i i i went to the finals because i was like oh it's the last you know um it's the it's the last game you know it's first it's the first versus second and then so i was like okay i have to watch that so i have to watch it so i was just like all right and then i watched i thought it would be a huge stomp on one end a huge stomp from was it rad esports i esports where uh uh where like they've been um winning almost every game and i thought it'd be a huge stomp because they stomped envy who was like um the other team like they three owed them and i thought it was gonna be you know best of five not best of fucking seven so i was like oh it's gonna be another three oh but then but then you know i was like okay rad won one and then but then No.
Because I asked, like, I asked, like, the staff and, like, one of my friends, and they're like, yeah, I think there's going to be a back and forth.
And because it's going to be a back and forth, it might be four, it's going to be, like, three to four hours.
So, I was just like, holy fuck, I was like, okay, I am not gonna be sitting here for three to four hours.
I'm sorry.
Like, I'm so sorry.
Like, I know who I am as a person.
So, what I did was that, I was like, I was like, I'm sorry.
Sorry, I cannot sit there for three to four hours now.
So what I did was I like, like I told like one of the staff, I was like, okay, I'm gonna go back to the hotel room.
And you text me, you text me when there's one game.
When there's like one to two games left, you texted me.
And then I went back to the hotel room.
I took a nap.
I literally took an hour nap.
And then I came back to the, I came back to the fucking venue to watch the last game.
So, cause I was like, I can't, I can't stay in here for three to four hours.
I'm so tired
So and then I checked I Checked my phone Joki woke up.
No, you know how I woke up?
I got spam called like six times on WeChat I got spam called six times on WeChat because they're like you had to get up Because I think it's gonna be the last game, but luckily I got back just in time for Envy to win another game.
So because of that, I made it just in time.
I literally made it back for the last game.
Wake up, don't keep.
So I just mean, just because Envy managed to win another game.
So they didn't get absolutely steamrolled.
Thank God.
for that because then i could i could i could make it back to watch the last game um game seven all or nothing um so i was like yeah uh yosh thank you for the super chat thank you thank you joki the ninja at marvel rivals hq also it was my birthday to 12 as well i'm 35 no damn i'm feel old thank you for the super chat thank you thank you happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday dear yosh happy birthday to you yeah happy birthday um but yeah so i didn't miss the final game um luckily i i i can't guys know you don't understand i was so i was i i don't i just like playing the game more okay I like ever around me would be like whoa and then I'll just be like there was okay there was one play which was very impressive that even I was like I actually gasped there was like there was one play that actually made me gasp out loud I just don't remember what that play was oh i wait i remember i remember i think it was um it was the wait which one was it it was like um it was a
strange alt the strange like did a 5k man alt i don't remember which team it was um but the strange did a 5k man alt and everybody was like oh and even i was like holy shit because it's like in a professional too in a esport match it was so impressive because it's like you know Everybody's a pro player.
So, you know, it's really hard for Strange to actually get, like, hit a giant ass fucking all of them.
So I was very impressed.
I was like, oh my God.
And, like, everyone, even the entire stadium was like, whoa.
And stuff.
So I don't remember what game that was.
I just remember everybody being like, oh.
And that was, like, the one reaction that they got out of me.
That was the one time it got a reaction.
of me um but yeah i got to watch the last game i don't remember who it was playing like all the all things blurred together all right let me show you guys my vacation photos chat i will start with this um oh yeah i want to i should move over so if you guys didn't know i'll start from the beginning let me move here sorry dragon i'm cut i'm gonna take over the screen now all right
Um, I was on, um, Cafe Pacific business class.
Very business-like.
Yes.
Um, um, it was a really, really nice thing.
Not gonna lie.
Um, wait, let me, wait, there's another, wait, I think I have a better photo.
Is that, is that me?
Yeah, that's me.
um let's see I almost posted this photo um I almost posted this photo but then I was like wait then people will know where I'm going I was like oh don't do it don't do it Doki um but uh but they recently upgraded their they recently upgraded um their planes so that it's actually crazy you can like close the doors now um okay i actually i took a picture of this uh i took a picture of it um and sent it to my friends because i was like oh my god i was like oh my god you can okay so there's a picture i took i can't show it because it has like reflection and stuff because it was a tv but basically um the tv you can click on this i don't remember what i told you guys about this but um you can click on the screen and it shows like if the bathroom is occupied or not i was like oh my god technology is so amazing because like i don't have to check the itself I literally click on the screen and it shows me if the bathroom is occupied and it's so I was like the future is now I was like oh my god I
don't have to get up I can actually like click and I took a picture of that and I sent it to some of my friends I was like look at this oh my okay the funniest thing is that I was watching boss baby
I was watching boss baby so it shows at the bottom like when my friend was like my friends was like why are you watching the boss baby back in business movie I was like that's not the point that's not the point, that is not the point here the point is that technology She is beautiful.
And I can check the screen to know when I can go to the bathroom.
That is the most important thing here.
The photo.
Don't worry about that.
This isn't about boss, baby.
Anyway.
So that's all.
That's so cool.
And then they also had a thing.
where um you can do if you have someone else i don't even i think like if they're sitting in like i don't know economy or any other seats in the plane um um excuse you many but that was actually my first time watching boss baby back in business where um the mr boss baby and his brother got are like older now and then like they turn back and then them and um the brother's kid uh work together to stop another baby and it's a different movie i have yet to watch that one all right so i've technically watched all the boss babies tv shows and movies now that was the one boss baby movie that i have not yet watched but now i can safely say i've consumed all the boss baby media so i i am the boss baby now i Why?
Yes, there's Boss Baby, there's a Boss Baby TV show, and I watched all two seasons of it on Netflix.
Um, it was years ago, okay, it was, it was years ago.
I watched it when it came out.
Okay, I, yes, the Boss Baby extended years here first.
Um, yes, there were two seasons.
What about the book?
Well, the book doesn't, I mean, I feel like the movies and the TV show was a better at, was, I never read the book even though I know the book was the original but I know I would be very disappointed because the movies and TV shows cannot could not um live up to the expectations that it gives me um and I feel like the book is the inferior uh like the inferior copy out of all of them because by when the book was main um they didn't have Alec Baldwin in mind
So it's so hard to imagine the baby being a boss baby when it doesn't even look like Alec Baldwin.
You know?
Okay, Valid.
Like, yeah, he is the boss baby.
Um, yes, if you guys didn't know, boss baby actually won an Oscar, by the way.
Um, no book has Baldwin in mind.
as someone that also grew up watching 30 rock like um he just i don't know he just plays the boss really well like anyway anyway not only that not only could i see when the bathroom um was occupied it had a watch together tab so you could watch something with someone else that's sitting some like i don't know it wouldn't be funny if i just do a knock knock and i just like randomly be like like,
hey, can I watch this movie?
You just get a random request from, like, some random person sitting somewhere and was like, hello, I would like to watch this movie.
I see you're watching this movie.
Can I watch this alongside with you and sync it up together?
So it had this.
Okay.
I even took a picture about it because I was like, what the fuck?
So it had, like, a watch together tab.
I was just thinking, like, oh my God, I could just like be like, Hi, can I like watch?
Like, I don't know how it worked.
I got too nervous clicking it.
I wonder if it's like, you don't even know.
You don't even know that this person is watching this movie with you.
Like, just stalking your videos and stuff.
I was like, because I was like, I didn't press it because I got scared.
I was like, oh, what if like they get a notification that like this person on a, like, at like, I don't know, 5C, decide it's like what's to watch this movie with you and that's pretty cute yeah and because i'm like who is this person that's trying to like watch the same movie as me like just some random person on the plane uh so so i i didn't press it but i thought that was such a cool feature i was like oh my god like what the oh also here here you go all right look oh my god i can close the door i was like oh my god it pays truly the rich have too many rights like i was like oh my god i can have a door i was like oh my god like the old cafe pacific business class didn't have a door so i was like um i truly had the ultimate technology right there yes 3k for a door oh my god pay to win let's go pay to win exists guys um anyway um i need to get more water i'll be right back guys give me a sec gotta get my water
all right what was that okay so yeah anyway so this was the very first uh we must eat the rich Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
So this is like the first picture I took um when I saw Hong Kong.
I was like oh my god there it is.
It was like super nostalgic for me seeing all of this.
Like seeing all the skyscrapers because like I don't know like when you're in Canada there's not a lot of skyscrapers.
There's a lot of mountains and everything but it's not a lot of skyscrapers um and like you know um it is a fishing village.
It used to be a fishing village So foggy.
Yes, this was what happened for the black rain This is why I didn't realize There was a rainstorm.
You can barely tell I think that was the black rain, guys Like I think that was when the black rain was about to start
But that was the first picture I took when I was like uh there's god that's kong kong and then this was me not knowing this is past turkey not knowing how fucked up the rest of her playwrights gonna be she's she's so hopeful look at the hope in here um yeah seconds from disaster i'm like yippee moments but little does she know little does she know a lot of shit was gonna happen after that um and then here's me taking a picture of 7-eleven because like i don't know i've it was like i got off the airport and i went straight i got off the plane i went straight to the 7-eleven i took a picture of it because i was like oh look 7-eleven no way look it's very nostalgic okay it's a bit i was i felt very nostalgic nostalgic um seeing the 7-eleven because there's okay there's there's a reason why and it's this particular drink so for those who don't know this is one of my favorite drinks that i get in 7-eleven every time when i used to live in uh when i used to live in hong kong and it's like um
i think is it yunzi gamlong um i think that's what's called but it's so it's mango it's mango juice so um uh it has like mango pulp i think it's a pulp i don't know it has like mango in it and like mango juice and everything like i actually have those mango pieces and everything and it's so good and you get you can get this at 7 11 and like literally that was like the first thing i got like i i bought this at 7 11 i was like i because i haven't drank this in so long you know You can only get this in Hong Kong.
So that was literally like the very first thing I bought.
Like I went to 7-Eleven and just bought this.
All right.
It's so good.
I'm very serious about this drink.
It's one of my favorite drinks that you can get in Hong Kong.
And then, oh, this one.
Hold on, I'm getting fine.
So I also got my favorite meal too.
So at the airport.
And I got, hold on, I'm getting fine.
So Hanani's chicken rice.
the with the special rice too oh so good i like i was like oh yum yum yum yum no it's not only available in hong kong but it just tastes better in hong kong it just i'm like it was so good i all of it and then and then i saw squid game and i was like oh my god squid game figures i don't know i mean it was at the airport i i just i just Why did I take a picture of it?
I was at the airport, okay?
I was just like, oh my God, squid game.
It's a squid game, I guess.
Oh yeah, here's my Laboobu.
I'll show you guys my Laboobu.
Um.
But it's the, what was his name?
Sesame.
And he's like, I know like this particular Laboobu brand is very hard to get right now.
It's the, what is it, the macaron or whatever?
The macaron?
I don't know.
What kind of, uh, I got, uh, what the staff member.
gave it to, I know he's naked.
For those who don't know, I have an outfit for him too.
Like, this was given to me by the Marvel Rival staff.
So, all the content creators basically got like a Labubu and like an outfit with their name on it.
So, I let me see what, I saved the picture.
Let me see if I can find it.
Oh, here it is.
Oh, my God.
That's a big ass fucking picture.
Let me let me resize it real quick.
it's just it's basically he has clothes so i hate you now little little cyclone thank you for the super chat thank you thank you um so they gave me like they gave me like hoodie and pants for my labubu plus um um plus like yeah um i don't even know how much they cost i know they're really hard to get i'm gonna look it up right now honestly let me see i know like the mac because like They're,
like, from the, I didn't keep the box.
I should have kept the box because I could, like, resell it.
I'm joking.
I won't resell it.
I wouldn't resell it because it was a gift.
It was a gift from the staff.
For anyone, the staff, you're watching this.
I am joking.
I would never resell the Labubu.
I will never scalp it.
Okay, let me check.
Let me check.
Macaron.
Because I know this particular set, you can't even get it anywhere in NA.
uh i can't even do it i didn't keep the box because i was like just too it takes it takes up too much in my luggage space so i didn't bring that box with me all right macaron la bubu sesame all right how much is it jesus christ 80 dollars no way holy shit it's 80 oh my god okay
wait what are the other colors wait a minute what are how much are the other colors because i know the other colors are more expensive because like the macro the exciting macaron ones are extremely expensive apparently for some fucking reason i think because they're all pastel exciting um macaron la bubu all right retail price retail price it's wait how much are they retail anyway okay no that's fake oh my god no way okay wait i want to know the box itself because there's i there's a lot of the fufu ones there's a lot of fufu um okay let's see okay pop mart the monsters holy shit okay wait so there's no way okay The food booths are like $10.
So I'm like, how much are the, like the, this particular set?
I need a no now.
I'm committed, guys.
Guys, does anyone know?
Does anyone have the, the data for the tasty macaron?
Holy shit.
Okay.
One box, one blind box, by the way, is $129.
dollars that's holy shit to to buy it it's a hundred and twenty nine dollars this particular color is only eighty dollars because it's because it's not the most popular one retail by the way retail is 27 dollars that's crazy if you buy it from the original because you can't buy at the original pop art store anymore retail for this is 27 and if you try to buy from scalpers or like resellers it's a hundred jesus christ it's literally plus a hundred dollars that's crazy that's crazy my sesame milk my apparently the pink one is the most expensive let me what's your name what's the pink one's name what's your name i need a no okay lychee berry okay I heard the pink one is like the most expensive one from my friend who's like a labubu like connoisseur because they're like they're like if you get the pink one can I have it and because I was like oh the staff gave me a labubu and then my friend was like if you get the pink one can I have it it's so it's one of the most expensive ones like like
I mean I guess if I get a pink one but apparently I got one of the cheaper ones um because it's it's the gray i got the gray one because like you know i don't care much about the boobus so i'm just like i mean if you really want the pink one i if i get it i will give it to you um
yeah i'll take it with super chat thank you thank you hey doky little birdie told me medi and fred are getting married can you give them your blessing also apparently medi's having a hard time finding a dress Any suggestions?
I think, okay, I think weddings are a scam.
I'm gonna, I can't say it.
I think, I think weddings are such a fucking waste of money.
I think I said it before.
Um, um, because like, oh, it's so expensive for no fucking reason, too.
Like, you gotta book the venue and then like, oh, and then you have to book the venue, which is also like crazy expensive, and then you have to get like wedding photography.
first and then a dress that you're only gonna wear once like don't fucking lie to me you're gonna wear this dress once and then apparently you have to pay for the bridesmaids dresses too but they have to be uglier than yours so they don't upstage you um and and then like i don't know people who do destination weddings you don't care about your family or friends you don't because why the Fuck would you make them?
Unless you're paying for their travels.
But if you are fucking getting a destination wedding and, like, expecting your family and friends to fly, like, overseas to, like, I don't know.
To whatever destination you choose.
And then expect them to also get you gifts as well.
Like, that's too much, man.
That's, that's, that's too fucking much.
Um, um, um.
But yeah, no, I think, I personally think, and drama too, there's so much drama when it, oh, and I had to pay for the flower girl's fucking dress as well, like, bitch, get your own dress, like, you're seven, you're not gonna remember this, by the way,
I was the flower girl for one of my mom's friends, um, I, I'll say, I'll say, I was, so boring but like like child's gonna be really boring too i did not but you you did not get thinking that is i was that child i wish i wasn't the flower girl i clearly you remember yes because i was no i wasn't even said it i was like no i was older because like i can't i had to fly back from china to go to her fucking life wedding to be the flower girl i was like i was like 12 like 11 or 12.
that's why i remember that's why that's why i remember um so you prove that proves yeah but you know what i i went to sleep at the dress because i was so okay i was so bored and i was so tired that like because like okay she was a one okay because it was like okay so it was like the pre-wedding the wedding and then the it was because you know okay for those who don't know um um they did like chinese wedding and then like western wedding so you know like the western wedding where like you know you're in the church and everything and then after that there's the chinese wedding which is like which isn't really like which is basically like a big banquet a big banquet and everything so with everybody we're like during it's sort of like the um so yeah like the the big banquet at the restaurant um for the chinese style wedding so she combined both so you know like the the bride would visit every tape the bride and the the groom will visit every table um to like do stuff i don't remember
And, you know, there's like mini games and stuff like that and everything.
So, and all of that.
And then in the middle of that, I went to the backstage and just went to bed and just slept because I was so tired.
I was like, this is past my bedtime.
I got this.
I was like, oh, I'm so sleepy.
And then she took me to the backstage, like the dressing room or whatever.
down on the couch and just slept um um but yeah no i personally think um giant ass weddings i feel i don't know i feel like i feel like it's if it's a small wedding where you're like you know really close family and friends like that i understand but the giant ass weddings were like you don't even know some of the people you invite i'm i just think like that's such a That's just a scam for me.
I feel like you can use that money for a house.
And I remember watching, there was this like Netflix show or whatever that was like wedding or house.
I remember there was a, it was like a Netflix show.
Where they asked a bunch of couples, like which one do you want?
A wedding or a house.
And then apparently majority of the couples picked up.
dream wedding and i was like are you fucking stupid like why the fuck would you pick a fucking why would you not pick a house in this economy what what do you mean a house is so much more like worth it like at least you can if you don't like the house you can sell it later because the house's value will keep going up until the bubble pops but then we don't think about that
house hurts if you don't like the house just rent the house make it an airbnb who the fuck is like just make it an airbnb why the fuck would you why the fuck would you pick a dream wedding um yeah but yeah no that's that's my opinion on uh weddings in general um but yes anyway um the I need to know how much is the lychee lychee berry la boo boo Lychee berry la boo boo bye I need to know oh it's like 90 okay it's not as bad Okay my sesame milk is 80 so like it's not as bad They're just like I don't know I thought my sesame I don't know I mean it's gray I didn't oh it's like you know I guess they're like ten dollars more expensive um um but i i didn't i didn't i think i didn't i think the gray one is not like as pretty but i guess some people like the sesame a lot yeah the sesame or sesame bean sorry sesame is it oh wait they actually brought sesame no it is sesame bean yeah uh what about the brown one apparently the the secret one what was it toffee is that the secret what is it no
that's not the secret which one
Macaron Macaron Laboobu Secret.
Chestnut Coca.
Okay.
Coco.
Laboabu.
Laboobu.
200.
Oh my god.
There's no way.
No fucking.
Okay.
The.
Oh my god.
Okay.
The secret is $276.
What the fuck?
jesus christ it's two it's 276 dollars holy shit oh that's crazy but it's apparently easier to find in in china for the boobus than it is in an na right now i mean they literally were giving it to us for free so an $80 labubu we live in a labubu society uh i got i got an $80 labubu for free yeah it's it's real it's not a labufu it's a labubu um anyway so where was that all right but that was my that was my my free labubu from the staff what 100 profit yeah exactly also my this out recently um let me double check the picture though i found this out because i just realized there's a tv there so let me double check this picture real quick uh just making sure making sure all right yeah okay so i remember if i remember if i talked about this before on the last stream um but so this was my hotel room and I mean look at the fucking size of that bed like like it was just for me like and um and it was for free too by the way so I was on all the content creators were on the VIP floor so yeah so
and I was you know I I came by myself so like I got some people that had like plus a lot of the content creators had like plus one and stuff so yeah for me and my labubu for me and my labubu um um so it was so funny because um i was on the vip floor um and apparently i just found out this recently but all everybody else like you know the casters the players um the the other like uh the other staff from other teams they were on the floors below us they were on they were on the the poor floor so and then all the content creators that got invited were in the VIP floor.
The funny thing is, well, I wasn't paid to be here, but the content creators, some of the content creators were paid to be here, so not only were they paid to, because, like, you know, the players weren't paid to play, you know, like, they were by their,
you know, by their org, but, like, it's not like, you know, net use or slash Marvel rivals, like, um, pay them to come over.
They didn't buy their flights.
they buy their flights and everything um you know but i thought it was really funny that we got the vip floor and um and then everybody else were on the floors below us uh so i was like hey that's right i am above all of you yeah it's like yeah i just found this out recently like i thought it was really funny that um we got the we were at the vi because it literally said vip that was the thing because i didn't know i didn't really i wasn't thinking about it but yeah the one above all but our floor literally at in the elevator it's the number the name the there's like you know there's like a tag next to the number and it literally says vip
I thought it was so funny
Because I thought everybody was on On my floor Because I was like Oh that's nice You know I was like oh I get to be on the VIP floor Wow that's nice Oh I can't believe All of us got to be on this floor And then later I found out Like because you know like on the elevator You see like you know when you get in the elevator With the like Other people you know there'd be people there look at the same elevator and then i just pretend that i'm just you know short like not i'm just like a regular chinese citizen uh just who happened to be in the same hotel and then you know you know they're all wearing their jersey and everything and they'll just be like on the 10th floor and then i'll be like i'm on the 11th floor that's right i'm heading to the vip floor um which i i just thought that was really funny
all right let's see uh what else what else oh yeah here is here's marvo ramas there's like it's basically just like it was the like wall next to the entrance to the venue so it just says marble rivals and then there's the there's the trophy for it they have a giant replica of the trophy outside too and um yeah the phototype yeah and then it's like you know marble rivals ain't there for those who don't know the tournament was at at the net use campus so um um so um the campus it was it was basically felt like a university campus in general so uh so and they have like four i talked about it before it but they have four different campuses scattered around guanjo uh for net ease so this was one of them and it was basically like its own university campus where it had like a pharmacy they had pharmacy they had a cafeteria um they had like a coffee shop they had like a little like uh 711 shop too where you know like people want to just buy buy like small things there they have like a hair
salon it was crazy it was just like a lot of minis and they had the peacocks oh yeah i'll show you guys the peacocks there for the feng shui for those who didn't know okay so they had a uh it was all men too it was just all male peacocks but they had a peacock enclosure um Feng Shui at the campus and apparently each campus for net ease has a different animal depending on what the feng shui master said.
So the feng shui master was like you've got to put penguins on this campus to up your feng shui and then the CEO put ping like sorry we got you gotta put peacocks sorry not penguins you gotta put peacocks on this specific campus and you want more feng shui.
what the staff told me was that each campus had different types of animals depending on what the feng shui master like like um um said so i thought that was like super interesting uh but yeah no i was just like oh my god there's the peacocks like there they are um yeah so i don't know what the other campus had i i didn't ask them um oh there's the coffee shop i don't know why i took a picture the coffee shop but there's there's a net ease coffee shop i was just like look at that there it is um they they like always um there's like it's just like you know it's just there to get coffee that's really it nothing special i was just like look there's a there's a coffee shop what a nice side oh and then in the coffee shop they had all these little figures too um apparently I didn't know this because like I know that the 80s was a very big company in China um but basically like these were like figures of all their out from their other games and everything um but apparently um uh Marvel rivals
is their first big breakout game um outside of China so they've made a lot of really really popular games in China whether it's for mobile or like gotcha or like you know um for pc they made a lot of very popular games in china but marvel arrivals is like their very first um like breakout game in like outside like in like na so yeah net ease is huge i know i knew net ease was huge um in china but i didn't because like they also ran different properties as well i don't know you guys know this but net ease is a distributor for chinese minecraft and i think i think they run chinese roblox too so they they yeah they they distribute chinese minecraft and the chinese client like and like for and all the blizzard games too yeah yeah so they run distribute they're like a distributor for it for uh for in china um so they're like massive i don't know if you guys ever see okay by the way i don't know if you guys ever seen uh the uh chinese minecraft but it's fucking wild there's a video okay i
remember watching a video of somebody who was like says you need to have your own you have to like use a vpn to access chinese minecraft because it has its own client and everything and it's wild oh my god like it's the there's so like there's a lot of like monetization there but like it's like a whole nother world like i'll link It was from Fundy.
Like, I was watching it.
I was like, what the?
I was just like, oh my gosh.
I did not realize you could do all of that in Chinese Minecraft.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah.
Wait, I had...
Okay, here.
I'll link you guys to the video and you can watch it whenever on your own time.
But I thought it was so interesting.
Also, Ania, you used the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
Need to pick a picture for you.
I'll let you guys look at my little boo-boo.
Okay, I used the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
Do you guys like looking at my...
Do you guys like watching the Chinese Minecraft video?
Royce Kill, Yavi, Lafie, Cyclone, Aphelion, Zecra, Medi, Vice-Size, and that person for it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh yeah, there's gotcha in Chinese Minecraft too.
I was like, what?
There's gotcha?
Oh my god.
There's everything.
Um...
Alright, what are photos?
Can I show you guys?
I have a lot.
I took a lot of photos.
Oh yeah.
This is the entrance for...
Plus that port...
That port is security.
This is...
This is the entrance for the...
For the arena itself.
But yeah, you might recognize this area because a lot of people did photo shoots around here too.
After the games.
Stomp, stomp, stomp, thank you for the magenta, super!
Thank you, thank you!
Um, and then here is...
What else can I see?
Oh, yeah, there's...
There's me next to the trophy tool.
Um...
This is the...
The trophy.
Um, the actual trophy that they get.
So they put it out on display.
Um, at the entrance.
So there's me.
There.
And then, uh...
What else is there?
Can I show?
Oh, here.
uh this is what it looks like on the side so you guys might have seen all the front pictures but i got a side photo of it
the audience was like really small like i said it was more so like because like um it's invites you know like to be able to see um see the land it's like an invitation so um so this is what like look like I have a video of it right oh okay it's a little creepy but I was taking photos of the cosplayers but like you know they didn't know I was taking photos of them but I was like oh I was like oh my god there they are look at the cosplay guys it's not creepy it's not creepy I was like oh my god there they are there's the cosplayers like they're there the paparazzi guys I'm It's not creepy!
It's not!
I just, I was like, oh my god, there's Luna Snow.
There's, I was just like, oh my god, there's Luna Snow, an invisible, I swear to God, it's not, it's not creepy, it's not creepy.
Okay, okay, okay, that won't show the other photos I took.
Okay, this is not creepy.
Okay, this one is not creepy.
The next one.
The next one I show is not creepy.
I swear to God.
Because it's like, I'm taking photos of other people taking photos of them.
Like, that's not as bad, right?
Right?
That's not as bad.
Because, like, look at this.
I thought it was so cool.
Look, there's Thor.
Look, guys.
There's Thor.
look see I was like oh my god there's Thor I was like there's the Thor from the movie and then and then there was also that I thought this one was really cool too this one I look there's the the malice invisible woman and then there's the then the other like they had The cosplays were so,
uh, so squishy is on the VIP level.
I thought that was super cool, the cosplay.
And then, and then, guys, okay, this one I asked permission.
It's like, look, guys, look.
Guys, look, not creepy.
Not creepy.
I'm getting a kiss from my Marvel rival's wife.
It's not creepy, guys.
Look, guys, look, look, see, look, guys, whoa, look at that, whoa, look at me, that's me, dance for me, dance, yeah, dance, yeah, dance, let's see, look, guys, okay, now, now I don't want to show you guys the other cosplays anymore, now, now, I'm self-conscious.
I'm not gonna... Guys, look at this car.
Tom and Jerry.
Look at this car I found.
Guys, okay.
But also, look at this car I found.
It's Tom and Jerry.
Look at this cool-ass car.
This was when I was lost, by the way.
This was when I was lost.
When I accidentally was using Google Maps and was, like, trying to figure out where the fuck I was um um but yeah oh there's here's Venom there's Venom look at that there's Venom holding holding my holding me and then oh here here this one I wanted to show you guys look it's me with my people it's my people look at me I found I found my relatives look like i was like oh i'll show you guys i went to a zoo i went to the the biggest zoo in guanzhou um oh my god it was so big i how by the way remember when i was like i want to shoot out pandas um um it was okay it was a little bit of a mistake to do that when i was i was i was the day i was getting sick so um i pushed my i didn't realize how much you have to walk at It's been so long since I went to the zoo.
And I forgot.
And it was like the biggest zoo in Guangzhou.
So, um, so I was like not ready.
I was not ready for that day.
Um, but look, there's a giraffe.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I gotta show you guys this photo.
There was something very special about this.
Okay, so there's something very special about this particular photo.
And I'm so sad.
wait i don't think i could show it on stream anyway
but the reason i took a photo of this monkey was because his
he was he was he was aroused and i was like oh my god
I was trying to take a picture.
It was me.
Oh my god.
I know.
Knock me.
I wouldn't have shown it.
I got the picture of where it didn't, you couldn't see it.
Because it was angled in the perfect way that I stopped harassing them.
Like, why are you like this?
Because I was like, what is this takeout?
I didn't take the picture.
I didn't.
It is perfectly angled in the way where you didn't know.
You don't know.
You don't know until I told you.
How is that creepy?
You don't even know.
Mr. Broken Bob Thank you for the Hakka Supa Thank you Thank you Creepy Creepy Jesus Creepy Because I was like Oh my god You could tell he was By the way That was the alpha monkey too Because all the other monkeys were like Really small And then this one was the biggest monkey
like size not not down there i meant like i meant size i i guess i was like whoa that's a big monkey
um but yeah that's why i took a picture of the that particular monkey uh That's why Thanks for the correction That's why That's why I took a picture of him Because I was like Oh my god That's a big monkey Stop burning You're so deeper Cut the street Don't keep bleeding You're only making it worse Okay anyway Anyway Anyway Anyway Oh,
see, Davey.
I didn't, though.
I didn't.
It was the picture was perfectly angled in a way where I could show it on YouTube.
And I don't have any other pictures.
That is the only picture I have of this monkey.
Please restrain yourself.
I swear to God, this is the only picture I have of this monkey.
Anyway, you guys want to see the other monkeys?
Look, look how cute the other monkeys are.
Guys, guys, look how cute the other monkeys are.
Guys, come on.
Look at these cute monkeys.
Look at that.
Whoa, they're so tiny.
Look at these tiny monkeys.
okay um wow look at these monkeys everybody look at that oh my god look at this panda no here you go there's the pad sorry sorry to this one kid all right oh my god look at this panda look at him or her i don't know there were so many there were like 16 they had 16 pandas look at them she is Not only a minute into society.
Look at it, it's so cute.
I did a video of, I recorded a video of one of them just eating.
That is one lazy panda.
Oh yeah.
Uh, where is it?
Where is it?
Oh, wait, wait, okay.
Okay, um, I'm gonna do, we're gonna bounce back to Marvel Rivals.
Guys, we're gonna bounce back to Marvel Rivals.
anyone has any other has any other wild ideas we're gonna we're gonna go back to marvel rivals talk
but i thought this was super cute so for those who don't know this is actually one of the this was actually uh one of the uh uh players mom and uh yeah this is like one of the players moms and uh um and they had made uh jeff like a little jeff bag um for like um for their son that was playing um in the tournament and i thought that was so cute i was like oh my god can i take a picture of your little jeff backpack and like the little satchel because like she was like yeah it was supposed to be a purse but my son was like you know he's a guy and he's like i don't want to hold a purse around so i made it into a satchel and i was cute he's like yeah so i made it into a satchel so he could actually like because it was supposed to be based off of the emma purse the emma jeff purse um so so but instead of making it a purse um she made it into a satchel so he could actually and i thought it was so cute and i asked her if she had an etsy or anything she's like no no i just do this for my son
and i was like oh that's so sweet you know uh you know like that's so supportive what a supportive mom like she traveled all the she's from um the sun is okay i'm not dox guys by the way i'm not doxing anybody this is public you can find it on his marvel rivals liquefedia you can find this on his marble bios liquefedia but the son is from scandinavia so the fact that like his family traveled all the way from like you know scat how is that not toxic i swear i it's it's on the liquefedia but they're from but because somebody stopped this work Tossing and creeped shots.
But basically, like, you know, like his entire family came from Scandinavia.
The Toki vacation situation is crazy.
Toki never take a vacation again.
They came all the way to Scandinavia to support him.
I thought that was, like, super cute, you know?
I thought that was incredibly cute that um um that you know but and the fact that she made the the little jeff put like little jeff bag for him for the tournament carry around and so that's yeah it's a sick backpack it is it is a sick backpack black fire thank you for the super chat there's nothing wrong with the backpack uh anyway i'm gonna dox one of the dogs look at this cute corgi this is one of my one of my the like um the staff member friends that i became friends with and this is her dog i don't remember her name but he's he's 12 years old uh i don't get someone to stop this and so he's so cute look cute he is he's 12 years old he's not a puppy guys he doesn't seem that old though he did not seem that old uh no i swear to god he did not seem that old when i like saw him um but oh my gosh i basically it was like a um it was basically what the dinner i told you guys it was the it was the dinner i had with some of the staff members and like staff member one of the staff member um
um invited me to and we had like beer and everything so it was like a really good like cool like it was like this all you like um it's a square place so it started out like this and then like it became like and then it got bigger and then it got turned into this it was so good though oh my god it was so yeah like we started out like this and then it it was like more she showed bedrock geo gets her man dog upside down thank you for the super chat thank you thank you yeah but it was so fucking good holy shit and then afterwards we i showed this picture before but afterwards we we gave the takeout one of the staff members encountered like uh like me and one of the staff members encounter while we were waiting for the one the other one to pay the bill um me and the other staff members encountered a stray cat and we're feeding the stray cat the takeout that like the extra skewers that we had left so we're like here you're here you have some meat yeah we're like have some meat little one
that i was super cute um because it was just like lounging the cat was just lounging around at the restaurant too there's so many street cats there's so many street cats around um let's see what other stuff can i show you guys oh my god i forgot to show you guys this i can i'll never i can never escape i didn't want to post this earlier because this is basically at the hotel but i can never escape you there's carfield there's fucking you can play carfield car there's a carfield card arcade uh i couldn't believe it i was like why is there car i did not realize there's an arcade version no it's for I can't like look how tiny this is it always comes back there's a car field cart um arcade machine at the hotel I oh I almost tried it I wanted to play I want to play so bad oh my god okay I'll show you okay so um there is this mall that I went to that was known as like the biggest mall
crazy um like it was crazy I was like really like let me show you guys the what each like it had like right it had so many random things I was like what the fuck where am I like and but let me see okay I'm just double checking the photo to make sure okay so this was the mall I was at and it was like the biggest is basically the the biggest mall in Guangzhou or like all of I think it's all is it's called the Grand the Grand View Mall and like okay like some of these things was like what the so I was like there's an aquarium there's the Grand View rainforest there's the Penguin Snow March snow world there's Adventure Land there's what whatever's park is and then there's Cyber Street I was just like we're what
so there's like some mini zoos within this mall like a bunch of mini zoos too and it's so fucking weird because this is not all there is there's more to this by the way there were more sides i didn't take a picture of the other side because there's like dino land too um no you guys want to see what cyber shiba street was crazy cyber street was the arcade area but like look at this shit is look at this look look it's literally a mecca fucking bull like there was it was a giant fucking mecca bull um at cyber street uh yeah that's that it was so tall it was like it was like i don't know how to explain how tall it was it was so fucking big um but there was like a i can take it but not only that there was like okay so it was like a small it was like an arcade filled with everything but on the other floors there was like taxidermy animals i was like why are they taxidermy and then in a different floor there was an area where it's just taxidermy animals like different kinds of animals there
was like lions and like it was crazy i was like where am i like it's taxidermy they're like actual real animal like you know dead animals but like um but it was like um of different types of animals so beside yeah it's beside the mcdonald's um so and it was like there was like lions there was tigers there was like all different types of animals there i was like what the fuck where am i and then on another floor there's a museum there's a wax museum of important inventors i so so Like,
it's so weird.
So, there was more in the hallway.
Like, if you turn left, there was a hallway of, like, more wax figures of, important inventors of, like, around the world.
Because that's so weird.
So, so there were, like, all different inventors and stuff.
And, like, it was, like, wax figures.
And I was, like, I was so confused.
I was, like, what?
And then there's Dino Land where there's like fossils and like, you know, like fossils and like, you know, dinosaur bones and whatever, like constructing and everything.
And yeah, it's like, it's all over the place.
Like, and then on another floor, on another area, let me find the fucking Dino Land picture.
I'm like, what the fuck am I?
Okay, here you go.
There's a kid riding, look, see?
There's, here's, there's a Sedona area.
And you can ride a, I guess you can ride a dinosaur.
So, yeah, it was just, there was, there were so many different things.
Like, and, and, and then, and then there's like the traditional, and then there's like, like, nice like I guess like the class like there's like a really classy area where it's like Chinese history too so then then we're like transported to like I don't know like during like the I don't know what's called like the three kingdom era where then then there's this area where it's like you you pass through and it's like all of these like little like chinese um history um architecture and everything and then on the side it's like uh like the dynasty era eras like different dynasties and you can like just walk through here and read like the like and in the front there's like little like like old architecture like you know like architecture of like chinese buildings and stuff the more you go forage there was just so many i didn't explore the entire mall i was only at that mall for three hours there were so many other things i couldn't even like explore at all like there was oh here i was at
the i i went to the rainforest because i got curious because i was like what the fuck is in um the rainforest and i thought this was really funny um because there's forest poopoo i I because they're like like your arm There's like a rainforest area where it was like a miniature zoo So I because I got really curious by the way It was also really funny because all around All around this area Like the figures I don't know because you guys could see in the background But the figures were um Um what's the word what's bootleg bootleg zootopia figures in the back don't you notice i don't i don't know there is basically like bootleg zootopia statues in the back um but don't worry i took more because i got really curious because wait did i actually did i take more i know i did but i don't think i like saved it on my pc um but yeah you can sort of see on the far right like the the fox guy from utopia um oh yeah here i thought this was really pretty and then this was a different area too like
it's it was so many like this was a different section as well there was like i said it was like this mall was fucking crazy i didn't even explore everything too i was only there for three hours because i was feeling like i was feeling like sick so then i was like tired and everything so i decided to like leave after three hours because it was a very big mall there was so many things
yeah it was like everything was just there um oh wait uh what else can i show you guys oh i thought this was funny okay during the cyber street they had like these wild arcade machines like i was like wait i would bro i want to play i thought this arcade machine was wild like I don't know,
it looked really fucking fun.
Yeah, you're wrong.
I didn't buy any coins.
I was just exploring the arcade.
Yeah, that looks cool as hell.
It looked really fun.
They even had a shooting range, too, to test your accuracy.
Like, you know, like the Olympics pistol stuff?
They had, like, a little...
Like, there's no real bullets.
It was, like, I don't know.
I don't know.
Maybe, like, Airsoft or some shit.
But they had, like, a little shooting range.
range too at the archive um what else can i show you guys oh i thought this was wait what is this oh i thought this was funny only big wait let me double check this picture real fast before i show it uh i need to double check this picture
okay never mind i don't know i can't tell okay i'll explain the photo so it's basically like it's an arcade um it's an arcade but it's like a crane machine and it was so funny because the prize was like coke like not not not not drugs but like Coca-Cola it was Coca-Cola and Sprite I was like there's no way like I could just buy Coca-Cola like Like I could just,
I was just like, it was a crane machine or a can of cola.
Yeah,
I was like, wait, I was just like, why?
It's not about the prize, Toki.
I was just like, bro, like this, I could just buy, I could just buy cola.
And I'm pretty sure it's cheaper than the token.
I don't know how expensive it was I was just like why is that an option um oh here's here's more photos of the dog guys here's more photos of him there it is that's right look at him I asked consent to take a picture of her dog it was not just so people know it was not a creepy shot all right he's so cute he is he's very cute oh yeah i took a picture of this because i thought it was really funny um um like because i showed this i was like oh can i show these and they're like wait why did you take a picture of this i was like there's why is there so much food okay so um i took a picture of this because i thought it was really funny because um um even though there's like a cafeteria.
Okay, let me double check, though.
Let me double check.
There's a lot of windows.
I just realized I was like, whoa.
Okay.
Okay, I took a picture of this because I thought it was really funny how... Wait, where is it?
Wait, where did I save it, though?
Where the fuck did I save it?
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to find it.
is it uh oh here it is this poor security guy i thought it was really funny so when i when i had to leave whenever i leave or like go into the um go there's just a bunch of like bunch of people or like delivery guys just lining up and putting food on the counter because i was just like to get um but i thought it was just really funny that there was and then like the staff was like oh that's not even that's not even that bad it gets worse at lunchtime because it was just like a bunch of people just delivery people in behind me just like lighting up to put trying to put food at the counters and everything for all the staff that's ordering out um and i thought that was really funny because i was just like that's so much food yeah that's the campus entrance oh yeah So,
I mean, it literally looks like a university campus.
Let me see.
I have, I took a photo of like the, it really just looks like a university campus.
If you look, see.
Like, doesn't it?
It just, it looks like a university campus.
So there are several buildings all around.
And you just like, you know, you just go for it.
Yeah.
It was really cool.
It really did.
Um, oh, sorry.
what else can i show you guys what else um let's see oh yeah i posted this on twitter um i'm not showing the second photo because i'm worried that youtube will think it's something else um but um i gave my tomato plushie uh to the studio because i brought it over for the you know in the chair photo and i gave it to the studio and the staff so then she like she took photos of it for me she was like oh he um the tim your baby is um enjoying his time um with my baby and then she took she sent me this picture but i can't i can't show you the other picture um because
I don't want YouTube to, I don't want to get strict by YouTube.
It's very sus looking.
It's so bad.
Because when she sent me the other picture, I was like, what the fuck?
I was just like, what the fuck is this?
i'll link it i'll link it guys i'll link it but i that's why i i didn't i i did not i'm not showing it on stream because i think youtube might not like that i i think they might not like it but here's here's the here's the link now and then you'll see why i didn't post the picture oh i didn't show the picture on stream um it's pretty it's pretty bad but they sent me that picture And they're like,
your baby's having a good time on my baby.
And then...
Bro.
Yeah.
Cooler.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Joki, you were the chosen one.
It was said you would destroy the creep.
Not join the bring balance to the normal.
Not leave it in sus.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
um oh yeah i also posted this on twitter but this is guan guan for those who don't know guan guan his he's like the uh the jeff captain of like overwatch so he's like the head dev so he does the dev updates and everything and everybody call him it's funny even um his i thought this was like a um an n a joke where everyone be like guan guan here but apparently like that's a phrase that um people um the chinese community also used too they're like guan guan here um but yeah he's like he's yeah he's john marvel rivals so he's literally the he's literally the dev uh the head like creative dev of uh marble rivals yeah yeah so um and then you can see psylock on the far right
oh wait i could talk okay i'm gonna talk about it um oh wait no i can't Fuck, I can't talk about it.
Okay, remember the...
Add me in two months, and then I'll talk about this funny story.
Because I don't think I'm allowed to yet.
Add me in two months, and then I'll remember the tea.
And then I'll tell you the funny story.
Let me check.
Let me check this photo real quick before I show it.
But they gave me a little goodie bag, too.
Like the official goodie bag.
And I opened one...
They gave me, like, a blind box or something, too.
Okay, so this was the official goodie bag that all the content creators and players got.
So I got, like, a hat, a little pop mart, Marvel Rivals, photo frame.
I don't know what I have, but I have it here right now on me.
But I'll unbox it.
And then there's the, you know, there's, like, all the little goodies stuff they gave me.
it now whoops I already broke the box whoopsie yeah it's really nice it's really cute free stuff I always like free stuff oh my god I'm just gonna break the box I'm not gonna keep the box okay what did I get what it fish oh wait no is this scarlet wait who's this oh I got Wanda oh I got I'm not gonna open it.
I got Wanda.
I mean, I want a Loki.
I want a Loki.
Yeah, I got Wanda.
I had a Loki or... Loki or Iron Man.
I'm not Wanda fan.
Who's Wanda?
Scarlet Witch.
Yeah.
Boo!
I love Wanda.
I've never watched Wanda Vision.
Okay, I never, I don't watch Marvel movies.
I say as I told you guys, I'm a DC girl.
Movies-wise, animated film slash movie-wise.
But gaming-wise, I'm a Marvel girl.
DC doesn't have good games.
Gaming-wise, I'm a Marvel girl.
But the only Marvel films I did watch and I did like are Guardians of the Galaxy, all three of the movies.
The first Thor movie, because I'm a low-key girl, I was one of those, I was one of the like the Tom Hilsson girls, just so you know, on Tumblr, I was...
Yes!
And I watched Endgame.
Of course you are.
I didn't even watch any of the Avengers movies.
I just went straight to endgame Because one of my friends was like you never watched endgame and then I didn't tell her that I never even watched the Avengers movie and they're like we're gonna watch endgame and I was so confused.
I was so confused.
I just went straight to endgame.
Yeah.
Um like the last movie um bro yeah because like bro was like i can't believe you've never even watched endgame i was like i don't never never watched endgame so yeah so i watched the last avengers movie and none of the other avenger movies um nope not even infinity war literally went straight to the last movie um oh and atman because i like um what's his name fuck I like him as I like the actor but I already forgot his name I know the guy I know like I know him no I don't know him but what's his name what's the name I like the I like the actor because I love like like all the comedy stuff he does Paul Rudd yes I fucking love Paul Rudd I love all the shit he does he's just so likable you know he seems so fucking genuine he seems like such a genuine person and I love yeah I love Paul Rudd he's just so fucking funny um I remember I watched an interview and like his kid was like a huge Marvel fan and and then Paul Rudd was that you know Paul Rudd was like I was like I don't remember it was
like son or daughter but like he's like um oh my god dad you got into you got into the Marvel Cinematic Universe who are you playing and then Paul Rudd Paul Rudd was like Ant-Man and then his kid was so disappointed And it's like, it's like, hey kid, your dad's a superhero now.
Like, is, am I your favorite superhero?
And then his kid was like, no.
He's like, hey, can I talk to you?
Yeah, can I talk to like, um, was it Chris Pratt?
Dad?
Like, oh, you're gonna meet Chris Pratt?
Can I talk to him?
or like who is it the one of the the guy that plays the guy that plays Thor was it yeah his kid was like oh my god can I talk to Thor please I thought it was a salad yeah Chris Hemsworth I was like one of the Chris there's so many Chris's one of the Chris's Chris literally like 90% of the Chris's are in the marvel cinematic universe it's actually crazy if you think about it uh the mcu has has um the mcu has hired 90 of the chrises in the acting in hollywood to be part of the mcu i like it's so hard to keep track the grace army there's like four or five or something uh yeah um there's yeah chris evan chris evans chris emsworth um chris pratt um and then is chris pine in there i don't know isn't he like one of the side characters or is he just in dc uh i'm pretty sure there's so many chrises i'm i've lost count i really did um but yeah uh but yeah i never watched wanda vision and i've actually never watched any of the movies where wanda's in it like i think like wanda's in the end game
for like like one minute or some shit related to like vision so um i never so i'm just like i i have no feelings towards wanda i so so i don't i am just i i don't even like remember much about oh yeah about like wanda in general because she was like never like less than a minute
Oh, yeah, um, I wanted to get an autograph.
Like, I did get, I got an autograph from the entire team.
Okay, the fun, okay, it was so sad.
I wanted to get an autograph with, um, this team.
And, um, so, like, you know, watch them one, because luckily I came back when they played the last game, luckily.
Um, but I wanted to get, like, envy as well.
But, like, the moment, the moment they lost, they left, they left the building.
because like i was waiting outside like because i didn't want like because like people were leaving and i was trying to be like incognito and then like i was waiting outside and then like all like everybody in envy just like packed instantly packed their things and just left and yeah yeah they were they were they were so sad and then i was talking to one of the staff members i was like we think it's a bad idea if i ask them for their autographs in the elevator
They're like, no, I think it's a bad idea.
Because I was like, I guess I was like, they're like, I was like, I don't think they want to give you an autograph.
I right now, like, what if like, what if it was in the hotel lobby?
I was like, you think they'll be, they'll recover by this.
Yeah, you see, yeah, anyway.
like oh man i traveled all the way oh i didn't and then they're like no because then they'll think they disappointed you you know like they'll be like oh man another family disappointed and i was like oh you're right maybe i should and then and then i was about to like go up to them myself myself um to like get the autograph um uh And,
and, uh, and then, because I was like, oh, I could just be incognito.
And then I was stopped because they were like, are you stupid?
Like, two of them actually watch you.
Because I was like, huh?
I was like, wait, what?
Apparently two of the players, they're actually, like, watch me.
They're like, don't go up to them to get their autograph.
Because two of them actually watched your, your, your stream.
like watch like my Marvel rivals stuff so they know who I am so I was like oh but I want to get their autographs so so like I couldn't go up to the like so I had someone else go up to them and like sign my like sign a little thing I took a picture of it but it's on Twitter I didn't save it on my PC but um I have all the signatures of the champions yeah no I had someone else like go up to them and have them sign the entire thing um why didn't you get it before because i didn't think they were gonna win okay i i okay i didn't know who was gonna win okay i didn't know who was gonna win i was like okay i want to get i don't want to get autographs from the champions because i didn't know i didn't know who was gonna win so i waited until the finals And sorry,
like, it ended.
And then, no, they don't say that.
I got their autographs, though, in the end.
Okay, I got their autographs.
Fake fan.
Yeah, okay.
If I was a fake fan, what does that say about...
I was the only one that got all their autographs, though.
I don't think anyone else got all their autographs.
I did.
I tried to get autographs from Envy, okay?
I tried, but they like, they like instantly left and then I was told that it was not a good idea to approach them because they were so depressed.
They were so sad.
They're like, they're like, no, don't approach the doki.
I don't think it's a good idea to ask for their autographs right now.
So I did it out of respect, I didn't do it.
I did it.
Yeah, they left so fast.
It wasn't even over.
Like, literally, like, the closing ceremonies was still going on.
And they were gone.
Because, like, it was, like, you know, because, um, they were, they were, like, in the winners bracket.
Um, because, like, they were, they were, like, literally in the winners bracket.
And because Rad Esports came from the losers brackets, too.
So, because, uh, MV knocked, I think.
envy was the one that knocked rad esports um to the losers bracket so like nobody expected like people that's why they thought it was going to be like super close um so that's why like you know it was more upsetting because like um because they were meant to be on the winners yeah it was a lot yeah it was a lot of emotions and stuff
that's why that's why i went back to the hotel to take a nap because Because I didn't know what was going to happen.
That's exactly why I went back to the hotel.
Because I was like, it's going to be a long day.
I need to take a fucking nap.
I'm so tired.
All right.
What else can I...
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
What else can I show you guys?
Wait.
Let me try to fly.
Oh, by the way.
When on the flight back.
I watched the new the I did not realize that the door the explorer live action movie is actually really fucking good guys I'm I didn't finish it so I might watch it with you guys that um but uh we can be aware I know who's autographed to get toky probably papa smirt thank you for the super chat thank you thank you yeah um it's really good I didn't finish it because like the plane like landed by the time like i was i couldn't even finish the new door the explorer movie but it's so it's actually really good um i wanted to watch that i want to finish that movie of you guys so the next member stream um we're gonna watch the door of the explorer movie um the i the live action one it's it's so good it's such it's actually it was it's actually pretty funny not gonna lie.
Trust guys, trust.
Oh, here's some camels.
There's some camels.
I don't know how to show.
It's from the zoo.
I want to show you guys some camels.
Look at that.
It is a good movie oh here's here's Nimi there's like there's a tapir look there's Nimi there's one there was I wish I video recorded it um but there was like one where um uh there's one where like they were like literally like spraying the the tapir with like a And he was just sitting there like He was just like contemplating He was just sitting there like This is the life,
you know I wish I took a video of it It was so cute Like watching them like just spray the tapir With a fucking hose and he's just like There like relaxing and just like Being like this is the life Like enjoying yeah enjoying life Cause it was so hot It was so fucking hot and he's just like Yes Spraying me with more water all right what else is there what else i want to show you guys
oh here's it what are the stadium that was cool but um i took a picture of this because one of my friends actually know um level one crook so i was like look it's your friend friend got mvp but this is like the stadium area and like you know um like you know they basically like the finals they won i made it back just in time to watch them win they're all like lifting the trophy and everything it was so cool it's pretty cool oh yeah i'll show you guys the i didn't show this oh i'll show you guys this i sent this to snuffy
you so much.
Wait, can you guys hear that?
I don't know.
You guys can hear it.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
I said this.
Yeah, I said this to stop me.
I was like, I have found you.
And then she was like, what does she say?
I don't remember what she said.
I hate the I had to send it to her.
I was like, I found you.
No, she was like, um, it's the subtle, subtle messaging.
Um,
um, but also here, I'll show you, okay, let me double check.
I'm going to double check the, I'll double check the video before I post, show it to you guys.
just want to be sure you know just want to be safe you know also needs the bathroom here i'll put i'll show you guys the labubu picture again every time i go to the bathroom here check out my labubu i'll be check out my 80 labubu that i got for free i
have to i'm peeing a lot because i have to i've been hydrating because of being sick you know So I had to hydrate a lot, so because you thought I pee a lot.
All right.
All right, let me show you this video.
Let me see if I can show you this video first.
I'll be sure.
Gotta be safe.
You know?
Okay, I want to make sure that you guys are hearing this too.
Okay.
Okay, okay, I can show this.
So I'll show you guys, like, what the actual, like, stadiums.
Sort of looked like.
Okay, so.
I mean, this is it.
I'm not gonna...
I'm gonna lower the volume.
But yeah, so this is like basically what this...
So you see, like, it's not...
It was full during the finals, basically.
Because, you know, everybody...
But it's all like...
This was, like, I think, like, day one or day two.
So...
But yeah, that's basically what it looked like in the back.
So, and then...
But it was full during day...
Like the last day it was full.
Yeah, but...
But this was literally on campus, by the way.
This was, like, on campus and everything.
So, I thought that was, like, the really cool part.
Like, they held all of this in their own...
Like, in their own office area.
So, like, in one of the buildings.
So I thought that was pretty neat.
The fact that they didn't rent, like, they didn't rent, like, a venue for it.
It was all hosted in the...
In the NetEase building.
um so they had like a whole building um that could basically have the entire land area yeah i thought it was really cool um oh so here's a panda look at this big old big boy look at this big boy oh wow look at him i felt like he looked like like an uncle you know like an old uncle sitting outside the patio and He's like,
um, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
He's like, um, yum, yum.
But yeah, there he is.
He just looked like an uncle.
This is still my favorite video so far.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
It's...
That's my favorite video that I took.
Uh-uh.
It was a good trip.
I had a fun time.
I had a fun time hanging out with the staff and just exploring.
Um...
Exploring everything.
That was not a creep.
just said this so you know i was look there's look at this tiger though look there's a tiger look at him he's just chilling i had his consent when i took this photo i swear to god look at this tiger oh wait i forgot to show you guys this i don't know who this pig is But apparently this pig is like super famous in Guangzhou.
But I, because like they keep using his face in WeChat emotes everywhere.
And I'm so confused.
But this is a, I just, I don't know.
It's a famous pig.
I don't know who he is.
But people were like, like in WeChat, the staff kept using his like face as an emoji.
So I don't know who he is.
I don't know.
I see him.
I see him everywhere.
I don't know who he is, but he's everywhere.
He's like everywhere in China.
I wish I knew, but I don't.
I closed my eyes and I see him.
I don't know.
It's that pig from the internet.
I have no idea.
What else can I know I want to talk about?
Oh, you know what's funny?
Apparently, there's a KTV next to our hotel.
And, but the KTV... Oh, I forgot to tell you guys the story.
There's a KTV next to our hotel.
But, because, like, I was telling this story.
I want my friends about it.
Because, like, it was, like, one of the teams.
I mean, they told me the story about it, like, I think, like, yesterday.
They're telling me that they were like, oh, yeah, you know how there was a KTV next to the hotel?
And I was like, It's karaoke.
Sorry, for those who don't know what KTV is, it's karaoke.
And so my friend was like, yeah, like me and the team, we wanted to go karaoke.
So like we went there.
Apparently they were like, sorry, you have to book in advance to like be able to be able to like come and use the karaoke.
So then they were like very confused because they're like.
what do you mean book it in advance and then they gave them the business card and it was an
it was an escort service ktv
that's why i was six to the hotel i was like six to the hotel i was like
And then they sent me the picture of, oh, I wish, I wish, oh my gosh, they deleted the picture, so I didn't save it.
I don't think, okay, I don't think I should show you guys, because it was so suggestive.
I saw the business card.
It was like, it was like very suggestive.
I said wish I took a fix I wish I had saved the picture of the of the business card because when I saw it I was like I was like wait so because I saw that because it says like KTV it was a big sign that says like KTV and Okay, I'll illustrate from what I could remember.
I'll illustrate it on page from what I could remember.
So she was like, wait, let's see.
Okay, wait.
Okay, give me a sec
and then
Oh my god,
okay, okay
Okay, okay, okay
So this was what this was what on one of the it was like the front or the back I don't remember but This was...
This...
This is what I remembered.
So she was wearing...
She was wearing a bikini.
She was wearing...
Or her... I don't know.
Or it wasn't her bra and underwear.
I don't fucking know.
But...
But just...
But this is what... This is a... What is this?
business card side looked like where the the ktv business card and so i don't know i don't know if she was wearing a bikini or it was her bra and underwear but i i saw that um and i was just like oh my god
um yeah And so I thought, oh, that's why I like, they couldn't go to the karaoke because they're like, you got to book it in advance.
Like, you got to book it in advance.
You can't call this number.
If you want to book it, if you want to book it, you can call the number on the business card.
It was, I don't know, I don't remember, I don't remember what the microphone, what kind of microphone it was.
Man, I was thinking about the super chat, thank you, thank you, new outfit.
So, so I was just like, oh, that's freaky, yeah, it's just, it's just normal karaoke things, you know?
It's normal, I don't know, I don't know, I wasn't the one with the book, I didn't realize that was, I just saw there was a KTV next to our hotel.
I never realized what it was.
I didn't ask questions.
I didn't.
A good soldier follows orders.
I didn't ask questions.
It's fucking wild, though.
But it was a wild, wild, a week.
and a half traveling um i had a great time i had a great time made some lots of new friends um with the marva rivals team um yeah you should moral of the story is that you should ask questions i didn't know i um oh yeah oh yeah i almost got chance to network with the set i mean He followed me on Twitter.
I followed him back, too.
But for those who didn't know, I almost had a chance to network with the Sentinel CEO.
He's like a...
I didn't realize how important...
Like, he's like...
I knew he was very important because, you know, he's the Sentinel CEO.
And Sentinel is the number one NA eSport org right now in NA.
So they have a really popular, like, Valorant background.
Yeah, he followed me back on Twitter.
And he, like...
Yeah, I got a photo.
I got a photo with him.
Let me find...
I got a photo with him, but I never, like, interacted with him.
I just had someone else go up to him and ask him for the photo.
I just...
But let me show you the photo with Rob.
That's his name, apparently.
Rob.
Let me see.
Here it is.
oh my gosh and not this though not this but just so you guys know that's not the photo that's but there this is rob so apparently um he used to work at Disney for those who didn't know he he has like oh my gosh he has his name is Rob Moore and he used to work as a was it executive vice president of finance operation for Walt Disney or for like the Walt Disney Company yeah and then after that he went on to work as the uh vice chairman of paramount pictures um so he basically before he started sentinels that's what he did so he has like he basically knows a lot of like basically like actual like move celebrities and movie actors and like a lot of famous people and um he was always surrounded with people too so that's why i never like approached him because I was like fucking among us like so I could never like approach him because he was always surrounded by people who wanted to meet him and talk to him and then so I never got a chance to approach him but I asked like I asked like you
know I asked people to help me get a photo with like you know having him grip me
um anyway so he is the he's the CEO of Centrelas at the moment and um and so I almost had a chance to actually uh network with him or like just talk to him not just like networking you know just like I want to talk I wanted to like talk to him because he seemed like a really interesting guy in general um because you know he's basically you know he's he's done it all I feel like just it was like super cool to have like be able to talk to them so what almost happened was that when i on the ride to the airport um they told me that someone else was gonna sit with me and i was freaking out because i was like i was just like holy shit like my cover is gonna be blown like you know like i was like oh my god whoever that's gonna be sitting here with me Because I was like,
who the fuck is going to be, like, because I was like, who's coming with me to the airport?
I was so confused.
I was like, oh my God, are the other content creators are going to be there?
Like, oh my God, it's going to be so awkward.
And then later on, like, the staff was like, oh, he can't make it.
He's going to take the next car in 15 minutes.
And I was like, who is it?
And then the staff was like, oh, it's the Sentinel CEO.
And I was like, no.
I was just like, no.
I was like, ah.
I was like, oh my god, I could have got a chance to like, you know, have a chat with him.
The one time, the one time I did not mind being exposed.
Yeah, so I missed the chance and then I tweeted about it and then he followed me back on Twitter and he was like, oh, if I knew it was you, I would have actually taken that car ride.
So I was like, what?
Because he was like, oh, if I knew it was you that I'll be riding with, I would have actually came down fast.
I would have taken the same car with you.
I was like, oh, my God.
What?
Wait, you don't?
Oh, my God.
Yeah, I was like, perceive to acknowledge me.
Yeah, and then he followed me on Twitter.
I was like, oh, my God.
Oh.
uh so so i was very surprised i was like whoa i don't even have a wikipedia page what do you mean yeah i was like me bro you look up rob moore he has a wikipedia page i was like i don't even have i don't even have the bare minimum of a liquefedia page i i don't even have a liquefedia let alone a Wikipedia
he follows pros, ex-pros, esport arcs, and one singular VTuber and that's me I'm that VTuber, that's me
yeah so I thought I was I thought it was pretty cool I thought it was really cool.
Oh yeah, also one of the, apparently like, one of the players that got knocked out.
Oh yeah, apparently some of the 100 thieves players because they got knocked out or like they got knocked out third place came to the arena drunk as hell.
From what I've heard.
Yeah, because they got like, and it was like, it was, by the way, it was 2 p.m.
it was 2 p.m yeah they came to the arena like fucking wasted at 2 p.m by the way i mean i guess like drink your sorrows away um but yeah they but they came to the finals at 2 p.m to fucking drunk as hell uh to watch the finals uh sounds like a fun it's 5 p.m somewhere
be um um yeah that was that was silly um what else what else oh yeah um tomorrow i'll be streaming and also the day after that i'll be doing battlefield six on saturday because i wanted to do it next week but then i heard the early access literally ends on sunday so um so i'll be doing
on Saturday um just because like apparently it ends on Sunday and I don't I don't usually stream on Sunday um tomorrow we're gonna do Epic Mickey um actually maybe I don't know tomorrow I don't Epic Mickey or a one-off I don't know yet but it'll be a 1230 stream so I'm not sure yet what time um what time I know what time it's gonna be a 1230 stream but I don't know what game I'm gonna do um but um Battlefield 6 on Saturday 5 p.m.
next week i organized a sloppy sisters collab um on wednesday and we're gonna play majorino um because i've been wanting to play that game for a while so i organized i came back went straight back into work guys see i told you guys i'm not that lazy it's only like irl stuff that i might be lazy and i might i might need some it's a cry of health um but professionally business-wise i'm not Only when it comes to personal life that I might need,
it's a cry of help.
Business-wise, I went straight back into work and organized collabs and stuff.
But yes, next week, Wednesday, Sloppy Sisters collab at 3 p.m.
PST, Majorina.
And then after that, I don't know what else is going to be in next week.
But Saturday, tomorrow, stream 1230, Saturday, 5 p.m.
Battlefield.
um um many thank you for the super chat thank you thank you for battlefield make sure you turn on secure boot for it took me days to fix it by time i finished i missed last weekend's beta run what the fuck is secure boot i don't know what that means but i'll figure that out later thank you for the super chat thank you thank you thank you well thank you for the super chat thank you thank you you still haven't answered your does many and frail have your blessing for the wedding what happens if i say no I ruined your happiness?
Good.
Oh, boy.
It's more exciting when it's illegal.
You know, like, what is it called?
It's like Romeo and Juliet, you know?
It's more exciting when it's forbidden.
Toki, you monster.
Yeah.
Toki, no.
Guys, I grew up on Tumblr.
Guys, it's...
Guys, I grew up on Tumblr, guys.
Maddie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Please see.
No.
That's right.
We'll make it more forbidden.
um anyways all right oh my gosh i yafed for almost three hours i didn't i missed my dragon so i missed you guys i was streamed in so long um i feel revitalized because i told you guys like before i was feeling like super exhausted um but i yafed a lot today and i hope you guys enjoyed today's stream just hanging out with me and um and you know um um let me show you guys my photos and videos my trip um but i hope you guys enjoyed my little recap and everything um and how i was not being creepy i was not i was just i was just being a tourist i was just i was just you know exploring exploring guys um anyways uh i'm gonna head off now i'm gonna relax i need to buy more water because i ran out of water um and i am I already had dinner though before before stream so I don't need to get any food I just need to buy some buy some water I ran out of tissue boxes too so I literally just ran out of tissues to blow my nose today or like during the stream so I'm gonna have to uh get some tissue
boxes and um and uh toilet paper oh my gosh I just need a refresh all my essential stuff I didn't do that before I leave I was like oh I'm running low on the basic essentialist I was like future Tokyo will handle this and I came back I was like one roll of toilet paper and I was like it's getting very low guys it's that one roll of toilet paper is getting very low right now so I should I should really restock on uh the essential item like you sure don't keep did not handle it yeah anyway anyway as always everybody say hydrate say hydrated posh check it out I'm around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to bed cause you deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye